and welcome to this video playing Leland
Stein lemony until new areas from
Argentina's this is right o el sabado
I'm sorry yeah Argentina's lighter yeah
it's a lighter flag okay so we got them
english defence against c4 and a quick a
three being played okay this is just a
spur-of-the-moment innovation let's see
how it how it turns out okay um would
like to attack the center will see 5 but
maybe start with this at least I'm not
bad in terms of development and they
have some pressure against the center
here a three was somewhat somewhat slow
move now that was quickly played
hmm
now okay that's probably the easiest to
play let's consider c5 maybe just
castles I mean this cannot be a really
bad structure I was just not sure how to
precisely play it hmm if i ever saw the
the simplistic way yeah come on let's do
this some probably the easiest the
easiest choice do you think why does
anything anything especially and I'm
just opening up the center to totally
equalize I believe huh
okay quite shocked Knight takes looks
strange and this gym be sure to be too
I'm not sure really I'd like to simplify
this that's probably better album okay
is not going to take right here
everybody and their uncle Abe you should
be too um I came yeah I'm totally just
need to take and once now maybe we
should be five yeah I'm setting up this
pin that's in fact important I believe
if he would be able to play Knight a5
one I b5 it it would have smelled
smarter trouble okay maybe I can okay
keep it keep it simple the night is
always threatening f2f five and to be
five so let's just don't do anything
fancy here getting the night to e6 yep
just yeah but I can block this and now
you've got oh and this guy is playing
really quickly now at the end he just
has a weakness on that form but he
played it quickly
ok so a six I guess so I am if it takes
I'll take d1 and king e seventh and roll
a six yep after the capture guide I get
it back and now I've got the D file it's
not carrying at all about this ok I'll
fix this a pond km rookie 795
okay i see i see so this is not really
working then i need to play with rube g8
also also possible
the so look g8 takes takes is there
anything tactical happening with see 5
or Bishop c7 I don't think so so I can
probably do this
now King here ok I can try to irritate
him with porn h4h look g3 but I don't
really put some don't want to put
something on the dark square so I'm not
really sure 95 now I'm morning all right
is this i can play anyway and now we
cannot go look g one because of rock t
three very important very important so
he needs to exchange rooks now and then
I get in 95 yep but h5 is not a very
unfortunate move here now because the
King might come to age form yeah I need
to
need to make sure that I'm covering this
maybe maybe this supposed to perserve
what I did yeah this that's not that's
not really great to be honest i go here
King g3 and this may be still okay this
is a bit of a gamble but check
can the upon its not not bad but ok he's
got the h-bomb really thats that strange
you can afford stuff like that
now you cannot sacrifice on c7 and we
can take I'm such a [ __ ] no I know this
is heartbreaking I mean oh no check oh
no losing this is really amazing I mean
wow how bad can you play and still not
lose oh I'm an idiot such idiot I mean
moves like Bishop d8 I just I mean what
just I'm just going there anyway losing
to Tempe and this end game ah yeah I
thought that this would be would be
basically winning but he had this e5
Knight c5 is just winning night b3 and
promoting I thought this would win like
technically but it doesn't unfortunately
okay at 16 seconds but still yeah this
is not this is not on I simply am simply
broke down here this is jesus still okay
it seems
now it's it's it's it's tough it's tough
to do with no time on the clock it's
it's a draw it k hear the beep point is
just just too strong yeah well the whole
endgame was suppose of course always
borderline between draw and bed for
white and was tricky to this side yeah
age 4 mm yeah but okay well it was the
right decision because he played the
most like Bishop d8 I mean yeah well no
words but okay I simply played it too
too simplistic I thought that this would
be okay but he has a c5 idea that was
really a good move by white basically
the only one in the game this one this
one if you don't do that you maybe get
some some problems here but even though
you don't do it yeah okay it Stefan
stand and 20-something seconds but of
course I just I just can can go to be
three and promote the pawn this is not
exactly witchcraft to to see that hmm
gee I wonder if around here around here
I have some some better better
possibilities I also could have just
taken here and entered also looked bad
but I wanted to fix the a pawn ma'am I
don't know I already don't know I played
it I didn't really play it play a ride
at the end okay thanks for watching